dans cette lettre de deux pages que
l'information est tombée edouard
philippe se dit prêt à retirer
provisoirement l'âge pivot adressé aux
différents partenaires sociaux elle doit
permettre de recréer le dialogue après
plus de quarante jours de mobilisation
des grèves très suivies ici la plupart
des syndicats ont fait bloc face à la
réforme comme ce 5 décembre dernier à
fort de france
la cfdt qui est plutôt favorable au
système de retraite par points les
réfractaires à l'âge des équilibres a
aussitôt crié victoire
nous croyons que si on veut aider le
salarié il faut pouvoir à l'époque
actuelle discuté et nous avons toujours
été les premiers à dire que l'âge pivot
n'était pas normal pourquoi parce qu'un
âge pivot à 64 ans alors que certaines
personnes ne peuvent pas arriver à 60
ans il ya un problème
edouard philippe semble vouloir ouvrir
le débat avec les syndicats tout en ne
transigeant pas avec la nécessité de
réformer je suis déterminé ferme comme
vous dites sur l'équilibré du système
l'équilibré financier du système
c'est une reste pour se laisser dépasser
par la fille de chef de clan et j'ai
toujours dit et je pense toujours à
titre personnel que l'âge pivot est la
meilleure façon de garantir le retour à
l'équilibré du système actuel et la
pérennité et l'équilibré financier du
système futur
le premier ministre donne trois mois aux
différents partenaires sociaux pour
apporter des propositions qui respecte
l'équilibré budgétaire en 2027
or l' annonce n'a pas convaincu tous les
syndicats comme fo la cgt m
et le s&p unsa martinique qui par
ailleurs n'adopte pas la même position
que sa fédération nationale
alors comment s'accorder pour la cgtm le
gouvernement tend un piège syndicats il
refile le bébé à ce qu'ils appellent les
partenaires sociaux c'est-à-dire les
organisations syndicales de salariés et
d'employeurs
mais en fait tout est déjà bouclé il n'y
a eu aucun recul de la part du
gouverneur
si aucune proposition ne permet
d'assurer l'équilibré budgétaire en 2027
le premier ministre sauf trois la
possibilité de légiférer par ordonnance
donc d'imposer ces mesures un mal
nécessaire pour le syndicat du patronat
l'équilibré financier est en jeu donc il
a dit il a dit clairement il faut les
retrouver avant 2027 2027 cédant 7 ans
donc il y aura un certain nombre de gens
qui partiront à la retraite dans cet art
donc je pense que la discussion est
ouverte
l'angle de tir était fondamental et il
est fondamental et j'espère que les
négociations permettant de trouver un
accord
le monde syndical paraît plus que jamais
divisés sur la question
entre ceux qui acceptent d'entamer les
négociations et ceux qui poursuivent la
mobilisation réformiste contre
contestataires